hello and welcome to this video playing
I am Rainmaker and I don't know said it
will upset yeah kind of oh this kind of
stuff III now you can play basically any
move against it even this isn't so bad
which is usually given as a reason why
this is supposed to be an idea a three
but it's not it's not a big deal like
it's completely completely fine him
what is that once to go F for it seems
spoon a3f for Teague's takes your phone
you can also just castle castle f 494
take screen each floor is that really
good okay we'll see I mean if this is an
ingenious trap all the power to him
yeah take screen age four and what's the
deal he will take c7 at the end and then
that is some kind of position hmm no and
why is he not playing in supply hey this
must have been some kind of wacky trap
line and this is the kind of approach by
black luck I don't believe anything show
me so we should have something in store
here
hmm weird yeah yeah I'm just the PM just
material up after Bishop s6 Queen takes
root create
very strange stuff
hmm yeah I don't know Bishop d3 or
something you just place this position
now on okay I take stuff and keep stuff
that's good very strange opening
I can even try to trap that be sure that
night night only has no square at the
moment he has to probably go a for him
and now can play all kinds of things b5
looks quite powerful no let's do that if
he takes a takes a takes it cannot eat
with the night and taking with the
bishops with the bishop will be also
problematic accelerates my development a
lot it's okay it isn't and maybe he had
you I don't know yo um maybe just this
and keep the five that way
check first I mean a chick first you
check it doesn't make any sense but
didn't that why did I play that move I
don't know
I would like to play D for him Bishop d8
Bishop to b6 this is a good idea why
didn't I do that actually KD 5 was kind
of hanging
this is this is pretty good check I
don't like to treat this very much it
should be okay
check maybe g5 is emotional don't do
that
the way I'm playing this is really a bit
shaky it's not very very convincing
check
okay so he's gotten this one I were to
do that I need some some way of keeping
everything protected we have six maybe
Bishop just six I guess um hmm
trying to try to go for an attack here
simply
it's still kind of kind of tricky Queen
g6 something like that don't i don't see
if we should be four maybe nebbish it
before it's good okay yeah i'm horny
much choice into this now Butchie to is
pretty good check check white resides I
still made it kind of tritium yeah what
a weird opening night would be five it
kind of feels like i had this on the
board once and it feels like i knew that
okay i don't know about that but I add
some blame but I don't understand is
this is just a lost position after
Queenie 03 / 06 why does the pawn down
and has a everything's totally bad and
this isn't clear think I mean I wanted
to do this of course and this isn't a
clear position i know i mean the
computer actually think white is
completely winning which is well yeah i
mean i'm not i don't have everything
anything developed here and here Bishop
f4 I mean my pieces are doing nothing
engine is on plus two so what I played
was bad so I mean here white is just
losing so I didn't quite understand why
he went for that and here i just played
it bad at a technical way probably
Bishop g4 was already winning okay check
yeah because here check he has nothing
we cannot interpose you in any
meaningful way check okay this I think
what a play is also winning but it's can
check
it gets unnecessarily tricky ya hear the
computer is again on on equal I think
you probably only sports it around here
somewhere when I got ya here after the
south side to be better again but only
here I'm winning yeah it's difficult
with the 40 seconds to play that
pollution 27 is what the engine is
giving jack chick and this which is very
very tough to play with lucky and a
blitz game it all kind of it's a very
shaky kind of position whoo okay I
definitely need a break here thanks for
watching